few of any prominent nicaraguan
diplomats have dared turn on president
daniel ortega until now
in the plenary session of the
organization of american states
nicaragua's ambassador arturo mcfeels
has to speak in the name of more than
117 political prisoners and 350 people
killed by his government
denouncing the dictatorship of my
country is not easy but to continue
remaining silent and defending the
indefensible is impossible
i have to speak out even if i am afraid
even if my future and my families are
uncertain i have to speak out
arturo mcfeels has been a
washington-based diplomat for the
government for a decade his surprise
decision to denounce ortega came days
after former presidential candidate
cristiana chamorro was sentenced to
eight years in detention for financial
crimes and so-called ideological
deviations
48 other opposition figures who've been
tried inside managua's notorious el
chipote prison have been sentenced to
between 8 and 13 years in prison on what
are widely described as politically
motivated and trumped-up charges
ambassador mcfeel says disenchantment
with ortega is widespread but that
public servants are afraid to speak out
days before our withdrawal from the oas
we had a virtual meeting in the foreign
ministry with a team of presidential
advisors i suggested they release at
least 20 elderly political prisoners and
20 other ordinary prisoners for health
reasons i told them that it would be a
humane and politically intelligent
action since no one should die in prison
especially if they are innocent and lack
adequate medical care they want me to
shut up
last month hugo torres who saved
president daniel ortega's life when they
both fought to overthrow a former
nicaraguan dictatorship died in prison
and vilma nunes tells al jazeera that
others are in critical condition
all the prisoners are suffering from
health issues for example former deputy
foreign minister victor hugo tanoco is
in a grave condition because of a lack
of medical treatment for his
pre-existing illnesses
mcfeel's very public turn against ortega
is not only an embarrassment for the
government but also a boost to opponents
who've just announced they'll have to
operate from abroad to remain out of
prison
lucia newman al jazeera